[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous je m'appelle
d'orient 10 bêta mais pendant une année
scolaire je me suis fait appeler
professeur dé des comme dorian et c'est
cette histoire que je vais vous raconter
là cet après midi c'est quand la
dernière phase vous avons envoyé un sms
il ya pas longtemps j'ai l'impression et
la dernière fois que vous avez envoyé
une carte postale c'est et caen où la
tête vos dernières vacances peut-être
encore avant et la dernière fête vous
avez envoyé un mot d'amour c'était quand
ou ouais c'était peut-être jamais en
fait
en fait je vous parlais de tous âges ou
parlé de l'importance d'écrire pour de
vrai avec un vrai style loi de s'écrire
pour de vrai l'importance de faire les
choses pour de vrai dans le monde réel
et pas dans le monde digital
je vais vous montrer que doit faire les
choses dans le monde réel
finalement il ya vachement plus de
sensations et qu'est-ce que j'ai retiré
tout ça finalement à la fin du touquet
mais je pense déjà que vous allez
changer votre vision sur des cartes
postales et puis peut-être que même nous
allons retirer de l'amour tout
simplement toute mon histoire est parti
d'un malentendu
vous connaissez le téléphone arabe
téléphone arabe c'est un réseau social
en fait mais 100% réel 0% digital le
message initial de ce téléphone arabe
venait d'une dame patricia que je ne
connais pas ces n'instituent trice en
région parisienne et un jour elle a dit
à ses élèves
je cherche des images de monuments un de
ses élèves l'a répété à sa maman sa
maman elle a répété à mon épouse et mon
épouse me l'a répété et moi au final
j'ai compris je cherche quelqu'un qui
voyage beaucoup et qui pourrait envoyer
des cartes postales du
monde entier voilà en fait c'est comme
ça que me suis embarqué dans ce cas
appelé patricia par la suite le projet
car postal donc à chacun de mes voyages
peu près tous les mois j'ai envoyé une
carte postale à cette classe d'école
primaire que je ne connaissais pas et
pour rajouter un petit peu de mystère je
signais professeur d alors pourquoi je
me suis lancé là dedans je pense que
l'explication remonte à loin quand
j'avais 13 ans j'ai eu une
correspondante sur l'île de la réunion
et on s'est écrit pendant quinze ans
c'était comme écrire un journal intime
qui me répondait c'était génial
ensuite je me suis marié j'ai eu un
travail j'étais auditeur
j'ai fait ça pendant quatre ans pendant
quatre ans j'ai voyagé dans le monde
entier à faire des audits chacun de mes
voyages j'ai envoyé une carte postale à
sylvie mon épouse est sur cette carte
eh ben j'écrivais un poème d'amour et au
bout du compte ça fait plus d'une
cinquantaine de cartes postales et s'il
vise à tout garder je vais vous montrer
elles sont toutes dans une grosse
enveloppe comme ça et croyez moi
sylvie jette absolument tout mais voilà
à la différence des emails ou des sms
les cartes postales ça se garde
alors est ce que vous vous avez déjà
reçu un mot d'amour un mot d'amour vous
savez ça ne s'oublie jamais et ça peut
changer une vie
je pense que je pense qu'on aimerait
tous recevoir un mot d'amour
je pense même qu'on devrait tous au
moins une fois dans sa vie
écrire un mot d'amour alors j'ai envie
de vous lire une justement une des
cartes que j'ai envoyée à sylvia mon
épouse c'est celle ci j'étais en inde à
hyderabad
c'est en novembre 2005 alors hyderabad
comme toutes les grandes villes
indiennes il ya du bruit tout le temps
c'est extrêmement bruyant il ya
notamment le bruit des klaxons jour et
nuit
c'est un poème d'amour j'ai vu le lire
chers sylvie élégante et souriante comme
cette contrée si différentes
tu sers et moins épicé 6-1-2 tu étais
charmante pensée d'un pays extrême
ton mari qui tu es
[Applaudissements]
merci voilà donc en fait mes cartes
postales je les envoie jamais sous
enveloppe absolument tout le monde peut
lire mes cartes postales les postiers
tout ça je me dis déjà ça peut leur
donner des idées
et puis y'a rien de ridicule à écrire
des mots d'amour
bon revenons aux cartes postales que
j'ai écrite à patricia et à ses élèves
donc ma première carte postale que j'en
voyais c'était ya à peu près deux ans
j'étais en suède à stockholm
j'avais ma carte postale j'avais mon
stylo et là je me suis dit qu'est ce que
je vais leur écrire c'est vrai je les
connaissais pas ce avec les enfants
avait 9 10 ans patricia je la
connaissais pas non plus il me fallait
un message qui plaisent aux deux il
fallait un message transgénérationnel
alors je me suis dit je leur parlais de
l'école du pays dans lequel je suis à
mon avis les connes c'est un signe de
bonne santé ou pas d'un pays
l'école c'est un lieu un repère dans le
sens où toute une génération prend sa
place dans la société
alors j'ai interrogé les gens sur place
je leur ai posé des questions sur
l'école de leur pays est vraiment dans
le monde entier les gens ont toujours
été super content de même pas de me
parler de leur pays de leur culture de
leur école c'est comme ça que j'ai
appris par exemple qu'en suède
les enfants vont en récréation dehors en
plein hiver jusqu'à -15 degrés à la fin
du projet je me suis dit tiens je vais
voir si finalement toutes les
informations j'ai eu comme ça en
interrogeant les gens sur place
j'aurais pu le trouver tranquillement de
chez moi sur internet
mais l'histoire des récrés à -15° par
exemple je n'ai pas trouvé sur internet
alors je dis pas que ça y est pas c'est
peut-être sur un blog en suède je sais
pas mais en tout cas moi je n'ai pas
trouvé il ya un autre exemple en
république tchèque des cours font 45
minutes
ensuite il ya quinze minutes de pause 45
minutes 15 minutes et ça a l'air d'être
une y être
intéressante par ice age n'ai pas vu sur
internet
d'ailleurs patricia elle utilise ce
système de pose toutes les 45 minutes
plus ou moins avec ses élèves
vous voyez en fait cette carte postale
c'est pas qu'une simple car postal pour
moi pour moi ça c'est un outil
pédagogique extraordinaire or pourquoi
parce que la carte postale ça joue sur
plusieurs sens
et on sait que ça favorise
l'apprentissage par exemple quand la
carte postale est reçu par patricia elle
la lit à haute voix donc sens de l'ouïe
ensuite elle est manipulée elle passe de
main en main dans la classe sens du
toucher
puis elle est affichée sur un
planisphère sens de la vue et je
rajouterais même un quatrième sens le
sens de l'odorat je vous assure la carte
postale à une odeur à la fin les élèves
ont appris plein de choses aussi bien en
géographie que sur l'école comment se
passer les cols dans les autres pays
et puis moi finalement jette ici une
sorte de lien avec eux même si je les
connaissais pas et je pense que c'est
aussi pour ça que ce projet a été un
succès ce qui m'a motivé aussi dans ce
projet c'est qu'il redonner de
l'importance à la correspondance
manuscrite
je trouve que la carte postale c'est un
bel objet à peu désuet rares ce qui lui
donne encore plus de valeur
j'ai toujours choisi la carte postale
avec soin jeudi qu'elle soit symbolique
de l'endroit où j'étais par exemple la
place jamâa el fna à marrakech du gouda
as good as des poneys ou shetland
j'essaie de bien écrire aussi même si je
sais que parfois les efforts les enfants
dû faire un petit effort pour me
déchiffrer mais voilà avec la carte
postale en fait ça demande un effort
voyez c'est pas quelque chose de facile
ça demande une sorte d'engagement
c'est pour ça que je trouve que la carte
postale c'est un outil pédagogique
extraordinaire aussi si vous si vous
pouvez imaginer le voyage d'une carte
postale
quand elle est postée de loin la carte
postale elle peut traverser des fuseaux
horaires des différents pays différents
continents des maires des océans
plusieurs océan plusieurs continents sur
la carte postale quand elles arrivent et
les crues et l ancre un peu bavé le
timbre est un peu corner l'un peu
froissé elle porte les stigmates de ce
long voyage
la carte postale c'est beaucoup de
réalités mais c'est aussi beaucoup de
rere beaucoup d'imagination
hun sen mélange de rêve et de réalité
c'est peut-être ça la poésie il n'y a
pas cette poésie dans les sms ou dans
les emails je tenais vraiment à vous
montrer une carte postale que j'ai
envoyé des îles shetland gellée dit
c'est symbolique et en effet cette carte
est symbole pour moi c'est le symbole en
fête de l'espoir c'est le symbole de
l'espoir pour tous ceux qui se sentent
perdus alors pourquoi parce qu'en fait
cette carte postale elle s'est perdue
elle a été postée donc tout au nord de
l'ecosse elle s'est retrouvée aux
philippines à dix mille kilomètres de là
regardez il ya un talent des philippines
dessus donc j'imagine le postier aux
philippines se dire tiens mais c'est
quoi cette carte là qui doit elle en
france elle s'est perdue il a tout fait
pour qu'elle retrouve son chemin il a
collé une étiquette il il a fait d'être
et là je sais pas après les serbes mais
toujours est il qu'au bout de trois mois
la carte postale à retrouver son chemin
en plus j'aime bien ce que j'ai écrit
sur cette carte postale
parce que il ya une idée sur les rythmes
scolaires que j'aime beaucoup je vais
vous le dire
en hiver les journées sont très courtes
c'est pourquoi les enfants vont à
l'école plus tard et quitte plus tôt moi
je trouve que c'est une
une idée d'adapter les horaires en
fonction des saisons
il ya aussi une belle phrase que j'ai
écrite c'était ma dernière carte postale
donc c'est important à noter et c'est
une phrase général sur les voyages et je
trouve que l importante pour les enfants
mais je pense qu'elle est aussi
importante pour nous tous je voulais
dire voilà c'était ma dernière carte
j'espère vous avoir donné envie de
voyager car cela fait grandir et ouvre
l'esprit voyage et fait grandir et ouvre
l'esprit c'est curieux mais ni patricia
lycée élèves n'ont douté de ce que
j'écrivais sur des cartes postales
en fait c'est comme si toutes les
informations que j'avais recueilli en
interrogeant les gens sur place en les
voyant pour de vrai c'était forcément la
vérité en tout cas moi ce que j'espère
vraiment avec ce projet c'est d'avoir
montré la tolérance aux enfants
notamment avec cette carte que j'ai
posté d'israël et qui pour moi un
message d'espoir d'espoir de paix de
tolérance
je vous la lire bonjour je vous écris de
d'israël ici au collège les juifs
doivent apprendre l'arabe et les arabes
doivent apprendre l'hébreu c o bli g on
espère la paix
pour moi ça vaut vraiment la peine de
voyager parce que dans le monde digital
n'y a pas toutes ces émotions même avec
les webcams tout ça on n'aurait pas eu
toutes ces émotions
je suis convaincu qu'il est essentiel de
se voir pour de vrai de se parler pour
de vrai de s'écouter pour de vrai de
bien s'entendre
bref des mets pour de vrai n'a pas juste
laïque et sinon on risque de passer à
côté d'une belle rencontre ou d'une idée
innovante
or vous souvenez au début je vais parler
des cartes que j'envoyais à sylvie
j'écrivais un poème d'amour
et puis maintenant vous j'espère avec
vous avez peut-être compris l'importance
de l'écriture manuscrite c'est pourquoi
j'aimerais qu'on fasse l'expérience là
cet après midi tous ensemble j'aimerais
que nous nous engagions à écrire une
carte postale à une personne qu'on aime
et sur cette carte postale à écrire des
mots d'amour ou si c'est trop compliqué
juste des mots gentils des compliments
alors qui est prêt à envoyer cette carte
postale lever la main hu alors restez la
main en l'air et signons cet engagement
à les signer super donc maintenant vous
allez devoir acheter une carte postale
d'écrire à la main avec un stylo et
surtout et c'est peut-être ça le plus
dur
l'envoyé et vous verrez c'est autre
chose qu'un sms
merci
[Applaudissements]